the media continue to play offense for
joe biden the world goes nuts after
woman kicks off in a men's football game
and democrats continue to push covet
rules they don't obey themselves i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data online with a vpn i
trust visit expressvpn.com
ben we're going to get to all the news
of the day in just one moment first
let me remind you that things are still
pretty volatile out there what would
have been a smart move like several
years ago taking some of your money and
putting it in precious metals i'm not
saying
liquidate all of your assets and then
buy gold and put that in the
refrigerator or something
i'm saying you should have some of your
money in precious metals so as to
diversify right this is just a basic
investment strategy
how about putting some real silver in
your loved one's stocking this year
that's right because now through
december 21st for every 5 000 bucks you
spend with birch gold group on physical
gold or silver or
investing in your precious metals ira
birch gold will send you bonus
silver it's the countdown to
inauguration day which is a great time
to pull some of those earnings out of
the stock market and solidify those
savings through a diversification and
given that we have no idea what is about
to happen
here's what you need to do text ben 247
4747 when you speak to your birch gold
representative let them know you want
the free silver with your purchase even
if you're investing in a precious metals
ira you still get the physical silver
delivered directly to your door text ben
247 47 47 get a free information kit on
diversifying into gold from birch gold
they've got that a plus rating with the
better business bureau countless five
star reviews
i know them i know them i'm working with
them for years we have been working with
them for your security where again
diversify with the people i trust text
ben 247 4747
open that precious metals ira get your
free silver before december
21st okay so the media's mission to
protect joe biden continues a pace no
matter what he does
it is the most wondrous thing that has
ever been done
and again one of the most irritating
aspects of the last
12 years in american life was the
media's decision
to make itself the lap dog for the obama
administration
then turn around and decide to be
extremely aggressive
in every possible way up to and
including propagating false information
about president trump and now they're
going to go
right back to being lap dogs for joe
biden
if joe biden is inaugurated on january
20th well cliff levy
is the associate managing editor and
metro editor of the new york times
and yesterday he tweeted out core to the
new york times mission we will
scrutinize the incoming administration
just as thoroughly as we did the
outgoing one
oh will you now how many stories did you
run on hunter biden
was it in the weeks leading up to the
election um don't remember
a lot of that and i i just i don't trust
you
here's the thing i don't trust you when
you say that you are going to be you
know
on top of the biden team i i don't trust
you and one of the reasons i don't trust
you is because
every few days the new york times runs
some piece talking about how evil
capitalism is in like its style section
it turns out the entire generalized
worldview of the new york times
is that the left is right and that the
right is wrong and then they pretend to
be objective and i was thinking about
this a lot last night
why do you even pretend at this point we
all know that if you subscribe to the
new york times
they i would guarantee you the number of
republicans that subscribe to the new
york times it's got to be less than
10 of their total actual subscription
base is republicans
it can't be 50 it's probably not 40 my
guess it's under 10
of the new york times subscription base
and again that's speculation but
i would think that it's pretty well well
verified at this point
uh or verifiable very small percentage
of new york times subscription base is
actually republicans or people who vote
republican or think about voting
republicans so why is it the new york
times insists on its label of objective
journalists
why do they care right we're openly
conservative because we understand most
of the people who subscribe to daily
wire
are going to be conservative and also
we'd like to be honest with you so you
know what you are getting when you
subscribe here at daily wire speaking of
which you should go to daily wear right
now and subscribe
in opposition to places like the new
york times so why do the media cling
cling to this idea that they are
objective news sources
and i think the answer is twofold one is
the self-flattering notion for members
of the media that they are doing
something of deep and meaningful
importance they are not just political
activists you see
they are of a higher echelon they stand
for capital t
truth and sure their opinions and the
capital t truth are exactly the same in
their own viewpoint but that's just the
charm
of the situation is that you get to
pretend that your opinions are actual
capital t truth and not just opinions
i think there's a second thing here and
that is that that opinion as truth
routine is not just flattering to the
journalists and pseudo-journalists who
pretend to engage in it
it's flattering to the audience all the
democrats who subscribe to the new york
times
like to be able to say to their friends
that they are speaking absolute truth
that they are not
expressing an opinion that they are
simply saying the facts and how do they
know because they're quoting the very
well-respected and very objective
new york times now here's the thing it's
all crap we all know it's all crap we
know the new york times is not objective
we know that their journalists
are not objective they all have a
political point of view if you can find
me
one trump voter one in the entire byline
staff of the new york times
i will give you a hundred dollars okay i
i am not aware of any
not aware of any certainly none who have
publicly said so right if they are trump
voters they certainly have not publicly
said so
that's kind of incredible for the
nation's leading newspaper in terms of
in terms of prop in terms of prominence
it's pretty incredible here's an
indicator of where the new york times
general mentality is
so over the weekend over thanksgiving
weekend they ran a piece by zoe
bieri in the style section and it is
titled
the rich kids who want to tear down
capitalism socialist minded millennial
heirs are trying to live their values by
getting rid of their money
slow clap for the spoiled brat to
inherit a bunch of money from mommy and
daddy and then
talk about overturning the system that
has made
not just america but most of the world
not poor
well done in new york times it's this
long puff piece
about all of these kids who never
generated one iota of wealth now want to
give away their family wealth and
pretend that they are in favor of
socialism by the way
if my kids ever come home and they say
mommy daddy i'm a socialist now and i
think that all this money has ill-gotten
gains
okay easy solution man you are out of
the will i hope that you enjoy your life
without the trust fund
i hope that you enjoy your life living
in an occupied tent while trying to
pursue
a career in lesbian dance theory like
really good on you
enjoy but the new york times touts these
kids as
the height of virtue because the height
of virtue is of course never doing any
work
and then taking all the wealth that your
family worked to create
through voluntary transactions we're not
talking about bernie madoff here we're
talking about
voluntary transactions taking all that
wealth and then proclaiming that you are
virtuous by dents of the fact that
you're against the system that created
all that wealth
so here's the article lately sam jacobs
has been having a lot of conversations
with his family's lawyers
he's trying to gain access to more than
two more of his 30 million
trust fund at 25 he's hit the age when
many heirs can blow their money on
harebrained businesses or a stable of
sports cars he doesn't want to do that
but by wealth management standards his
plan is just as bad he wants to give it
all away
i want to build a world where someone
like me a young person who controls tens
of millions of dollars
is impossible well actually if you want
that world
there's still large swaths of the world
where they're young people who can't
control any wealth
in fact if you would like to jet set
down to sudan things are going great for
young people who can't create any wealth
there if you would like to head over
to china young people not doing so well
in the wealth department right there are
plenty of places on earth you can go
and be poor really and most of them are
characterized either by complete anarchy
at the top levels of government
or by complete dictatorship at the top
levels of government so go ahead really
you are free to leave at any time you
don't have to access that wealth you can
leave that wealth in the trust fund
at any time you're free to pick up and
take a commercial flight to any one of
the places on earth where young people
are unable to generate
any level of wealth let alone tens of
millions of dollars of wealth
a socialist since college mr jacob sees
his family's extreme plutocratic wealth
as both a moral
and economic failure uh nothing quite as
charming as kids looking at their
parents and deciding that they are
better than their parents really a
charming charming thing
he wants to put his inheritance toward
ending capitalism and by that he means
using his money to undo systems that
accumulate money for those at the top
and that have played a large role in
widening economic and racial inequality
millennials will be the recipients of
the largest generational shift of assets
in american history the great wealth
transfer as finance types put it tens of
trillions of dollars are expected to
pass between generations in just
the next decade and that money like all
wealth in the united states says the new
york times is extremely concentrated in
the upper brackets mr jacobs whose
grandfather was the founder of qualcomm
expects to receive up to 100 million
over the course of his lifetime most of
his fellow millennials however are
receiving a rotten
inheritance class and inequality have
been part of the political conversation
for most of their adult lives
in their time the ever widening gulf
between rich and poor has pushed
left-wing politics back into the
american political
mainstream mr jacobs has both a trust
fund kid and an anti-capitalist is in a
rare position among leftists fighting
against economic inequality but he isn't
alone in trying to figure out as he puts
it what it means to be with the 99
when you are the one percent and this
article goes on to profile a bunch of
these under-headed utes
they're not that young right but they
act like children rachel gellman a
30-year-old
in oakland california who describes her
politics as anti-capitalist
anti-imperialist
and abolitionist her family always gave
generously to liberal causes in civil
society groups
she supports groups devoted to ending
inequality like movement for black lives
national day labor or organizing network
and critical resistance a leading prison
abolition group
yeah good luck with the prison abolition
thing and when it comes time to protect
your house
good luck for that she says my money is
mostly stocks which means it comes from
underpaying and undervaluing
working-class people and that's
impossible to disconnect from the
economic legacies of indigenous genocide
and slavery okay our country
you know what you're making the case
fine you've now made the case against
capitalism maybe
capitalism generates too much wealth
that goes to too many stupid people
and then those people undermine the
system maybe we're just too wealthy to
understand how good we have it
but the new york times is pushing that
stuff so spare me all the hysterics of
the new york times about how you guys
are objective
journalists when it comes to the
objective journalistic set
there's a very clear point of view as to
what they believe is right and what they
believe
is wrong traditional american systems of
free markets and individual rights
those are not among them okay these are
not things that they believe are right
okay we'll get to more of this in just a
second and how it applies to team
biden which is now being granted every
sort of grace
from your establishment media we'll get
to that in one second first let us talk
about something amazing okay this is
really an amazing gift for yourself for
your family i'm talking about
myphoto.com
you can basically take any photo on your
phone right they're just sitting there
on your phone
and you can make it into a metal glass
wood piece like these beautiful pieces
and it takes two minutes to do it and
you get it in five days
it's really really simple it comes in a
stunning gift box with the holidays
coming up
i barely need to do anything to make
something personal and special for my
friends
and family members myphoto.com they've
literally made millions of customers
memories come to life forever you try it
it's really easy go to myphoto.com
you just take your photo right you take
your photo you send it into myphoto.com
and you can see it
on all their products and then simply
purchase you use promo code ben25 today
you get 25
off i have a beautiful photo in my house
me and my wife
on the beach took me almost literally
one second i just went to my phone found
the photo sent it to my photo
i've got an acrylic piece came in the
mail put it on the mantel it looks
absolutely beautiful it's glowing it's
wonderful the only problem is my face is
on it other than that it's absolutely
spectacular
go check out myphoto.com right now use
the code bend25 get 25
off you'll see how easy and fun it is it
can actually be addicting because you're
just doing it every so often just send
in a photo
you get back this beautiful beautiful
piece it is easy it is fast anybody can
do it go check them out right now
myphoto.com you can see your photo on
all their products use promo code ben25
today you get 25 percent off at my
photo.com makes a great
holiday gift go check them out plus i
know the founders of the company
wonderful wonderful people go check them
out myphoto.com
code ben25 today for 25 off okay so
the world view of the establishment
media extends into their coverage
obviously
of presidential candidates and their
teams so
for example nira tandon we discussed
yesterday here on the program
near tannen is the head of the center
for american progress she is not well
liked in washington d.c
she has always been known as a rather
contentious sort on twitter she's spent
her time
being really really nasty to people and
not just nasty to people she's
propagated a bunch of nonsense about the
russian collusion hoax
she's gone after senators she's done all
this stuff now
biden wants to make her the head of the
office of management and budget
after running the organization center
for american progress in such a way that
she was actually the subject of a
scandal
when she went into a large company
meeting and proceeded
to name an anonymous sexual harassment
a ledger right just went into the
meeting just spilled the person's name
this person wants to be head of the omb
and republicans are kicking back against
that here is the headline
from the washington post it is not that
joe biden has nominated a highly
controversial pick
who spent her days on twitter being
malicious as all hell no here's the
headline
right it's all it's always republicans
pounds when democrats do a bad thing the
headline is always republicans
pounce when republicans do a bad thing
the headline from your establishment
media is republicans
do worst thing that has ever happened
mostly targeting women minorities
children and
cute household pets right and then if
it's democrats did a bad thing the
actual headline is
republicans pounds so here's the
republicans pounce headline from
democracy dies in darkness the
washington post
biden's pick to lead white house budget
office budget office
emerges as lightning rod for gop it's
just emerged
as a lightning rod for the gop you see
and it's the gop
now that is not newsworthy now the gop
opposes some of biden's picks
they're the gop he's a democrat that's
not exactly newsworthy
what's newsworthy is you know the stuff
that she has said that makes her
controversial does any of that make the
headline
nope instead the sub headline is nira
tandon who served in the clinton and
obama administrations would face senate
confirmation early
next year jeff stein annie linsky
and sungmin kim writing for the
washington post president-elect joe
biden's pick to lead the powerful white
house budget office
generated early controversy monday with
niro tandon emerging as an immediate
target for conservatives and republican
lawmakers
1050 has regularly clashed with the gop
in a manner republicans say will
complicate her senate confirmation
process
several gop senators said monday she
could run into trouble during
confirmation hearings warning that her
partisan background could make it hard
for her to win
republican support okay how far do we
get into this article
before we actually find out what exactly
she has said
okay the answer is i am still scrolling
not kidding okay she has not gone like
okay
we have to get all the way down to about
paragraph
maybe 25 here before you get to tanzan
has a history of more pointed and
partisan critiques of opponents than
does janet yellen or any of the other
picks
her supporters praise her passion and
willingness to fight aggressively across
a range
of policy issues tanzan's sometimes
adversarial approach appears to strike a
different tone than what biden had
promised
during the campaign tandon's comments
may not be out of balance within the
climate of her party
however okay so they literally don't
quote
any of the things that she has said
about people on twitter including
backing the steele dossier hey they do
not quote her going after individual
republican senators
not anywhere in the article so you can
read the entire article and still not
know
what is controversial about neurotandin
like nowhere in here are you going to
find out what is controversial about
neurotandin
nowhere in here is there any mention of
the sexual harassment allegation
situation over at center for american
progress nowhere in here is there any
mention of the nasty things that she
says on twitter that have made her
rather unpalatable for senators
because the washington post democracy
dies in darkness guys but
the good news is the washington post
style section
has really focused in on what is the key
issue these days
and that key issue is how melania trump
is decorating the
white house for christmas every quiz
christmas we get a story about how
melania trump
is basically the the evil queen from the
chronicles of narnia and she decorates
the white house
in a malevolent fashion so here is the
article from the washington post right
we we still don't know anything about an
irritant and from the washington post
but we are going to find out everything
you need to know about melania trump
from her white house decorations
that's literally the title of the piece
from the style section everything we
needed to know about melania trump is in
those bewildering
christmas decorations monica hess
writing somebody gets paid to do this
that's pretty incredible what a great
country
it's our final christmas with melania
trump and we shall celebrate in the
usual way
by accompanying the first lady of the
united states on an annual tour of her
white house decor a one-minute video
that also appears to serve as trailer
for a movie about a woman who wakes up
in a castle one holiday season and goes
searching for the person who spiked her
eggnog with mushrooms
and so here we are following the first
lady down colonnades and breezeways as
she encounters rows of looming florally
festooned evergreens
in the manner of someone who has never
seen a tree the decor contains many
roses white lights and hanging ornaments
airplanes speedboats
which melania looks up at and beholds in
wonder there's a painting of a reindeer
another one of a fox there's an ornament
of an american flag
and another one reading be best
referencing the first lady's launch
failure of a signature initiative
there's a banner celebrating the 19th
amendment which now comes across as
fourth dimensional trolling given that
the majority of american women
voters used their ballots to eject
melania's husband from the white house
what
stellar stellar stuff here just really
really well done
guys covering in-depth office you know
you know what i needed more of though
i needed more coverage personally me in
the media and somebody who follows the
stuff closely
i needed more coverage of joe biden's
pets how about you
i needed lots of coverage of that and
the daily beast is here for you because
not only
are they covering joe biden's pets they
went they interviewed a pet
psychic a pet psychic a person who's
gonna read
joe biden's pets minds from afar
this is the party of science guys super
sciencey we're gonna go talk to a crazy
lady who talks to dogs
sounds awesome we'll get to that in just
one moment how i don't understand why
you don't trust the subjective media
they say they're objective and they're
going to cover
the they're going to cover this
administration guys they're going to
cover it
in their own slobber that's what they're
going to cover it okay we're going to
get to that in just one second first
right now you're spending too much on
your cell phone bill how do i know
because you're not using pure talk usa
are you well if you're not using pure
talk usa you're spending way too much
money on your cell phone bill because
you're paying for unlimited data now are
you using unlimited data the answer is
probably not in fact almost certainly
not because it's impossible to use
unlimited data but not just that you're
probably not even coming close
what you actually need what you actually
need is not unlimited data
instead from pure talk usa you need
unlimited talk and text and two gigs of
data for just 20 bucks a month
and if you go over on data usage they
don't charge you for it so you really
have nothing to lose
so you could be saving like 800 bucks
every single year simply by switching to
pure talk usa
from verizon or at t or t-mobile you're
not sacrificing coverage because pure
talk has the same coverage same bars
as one of the big carriers but they
charge you half for it so
get started today why are you wasting
your money grab your mobile phone tile
pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do you'll save
50 off your first month
dial pound 2 5 0 say keyword ben shapiro
pure talk is simply smarter wireless go
check them out right now
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro again
dial pound
250 and say ben shapiro to get started
so that democracy dies in darkness media
they're not just covering nothing about
neuro tangent and everything about
melania trump's christmas decorations
they're definitely definitely covering
joe biden's dogs so the daily beast
over the weekend put out a long piece
from tim tiemann
senior editor and writer it is titled
joe biden's dogs have told this pet
psychic
a lot about their beloved master and his
future
my god without this sort of journalism i
don't i don't know how we could move
forward as a republic
without this sort of journalism i mean i
i definitely remember
this kind of sycophantic coverage for
president trump never happening ever in
ever but now we have gr like this is a
very long story a very very long story
about a pet psychic
champ says he needs memory foam betting
to ease problems with his joints
major thinks he may have dental problems
both dogs say joe biden's troubles with
donald trump are far from over but that
their master is calm and focused enough
to steer america forward
is the daily beast the biden white house
has sprung its first leaks but what can
be done
when the leakers are the
president-elect's beloved dogs and they
are communicating telepathically with a
pet psychic
in the english midlands it began when
british daytime tv show this morning
provided bethlehem with pictures of
biden's two german shepherds champ and
major
as a pet psychic who performs animal
communication using telepathy
and mind-to-mind communication crowther
from the county of worcester
uses photographs or can just be in the
same room as an animal in order to begin
she claims
speaking with it with their pictures she
says she forged a closer relationships
with biden's dog and wow did they ever
dish about their owner as well as a
ramping up of his troubles with the
non-conceding president trump
moving into the white house their
master's calmness and even biden's plans
to govern lee crowther told the daily
beast the very first thing i got was
they're both very excited about moving
to the white house
i had a real connection i felt that
excitement of theirs they showed me that
joe biden is very bonded to his dogs and
has a real connection
to them they kept showing me that
although he has rescued one of the dogs
the dogs feel in many ways
they have rescued him ah
and then the entire piece is about how
wonderful it is that joe biden has
dogs and this thing goes on for i'm not
kidding you like thousands of words
thousands of words with like wonderful
photos of this crazy lady
who talks to dogs it's incredible
like it's like a full expose of crazy
dog talking lady
talking about joe biden's dogs
so will she link up with major and champ
pre or post moving into the white house
leak rather laughed i'm not sure
if joe biden wanted me to i'm sure i
would oblige we will see i know and
believe in their love and devotion to
him and jill which is absolutely
marvelous i have every faith joe biden
will do a good job as president because
i believe
what these dogs tell me i mean i
hesitate to say a typical biden voter
but
also i'm just going to point something
out here if this dog psychic lady were
really that good
shouldn't she have like spilled to the
daily beast beforehand the dog's
assassination attempt on joe biden
because he broke his foot playing with
the dogs like
the day after this interview she's not a
very good dog psychic or maybe she's not
the kind of psychic who sees the future
she's only the kind who talks to dogs
or maybe our media are just complete and
utter thorough going garbage
maybe all of those things actually you
know i'm gonna go with all those things
okay meanwhile one of the key elements
of the biden agenda is that he's going
to appoint people solely
based on exterior characteristics which
is really exciting stuff
he is going to appoint a vice
presidential candidate who's black and
woman those are actual qualifications
not just a description of the person
who's good at the job he's going to pick
kamala harris because he was looking for
a black woman he's going to look
for certain members of the latino
community to be in his cabinet they're
people who are literally lobbying him
saying you need to have like five
latinos in your cabinet or this
is not a representative administration
remember that time that martin luther
king had this whole weird thing about
like judging people by the content of
their character rather than the color of
their skate yeah screw that stuff that's
ridiculous stuff
well now there's a real push for
michelle floor knife or secretary of
defense
not because presumably she'll be good at
the job but because she is a lady
she's a woman right now i hesitate to
mention but not very much
that democrats don't actually believe in
the concept of a woman right that is not
a thing
a man can be a woman a woman can be a
man some women have penises some men
have vaginas
right we have been reliably informed by
this and of this and in fact kamala
harris believes in all this gender
ideology nonsense because she actually
puts her preferred pronouns in her
twitter profile
we saw joe biden in an open town hall
say to a mother
of a nine-year-old that an eight or a
nine-year-old should be able to decide
their own gender
which means that he doesn't believe that
male and female are actual stagnant
categories
they are social constructs so what does
it matter anyone on the left
serious serious question if you can't
define woman why does it matter if a
woman is secretary of defense
what matters because again you have this
this moral hierarchy
in which the most wise and most just
among us
on the left they get to randomly shift
categories they get to randomly shift
the way all of this works on on a
seemingly
fluid basis and if you don't follow them
around then you are cast out into the
outer darkness
right because they are your moral
betters they are a priesthood if you
don't follow the priesthood of the woke
then obviously you are very bad so
everybody's very excited because joe
biden is considering a woman for
secretary of defense rosa brooks
co-founder of the leadership council for
women in national security
has a piece in new york times today
titled it's time for a woman to run the
defense department
oh good i'm excited that nikki haley is
gonna be the new secretary of defense oh
you don't mean a woman you just mean
like a democrat who happens to be a
woman
oh you mean a certain kind of woman or
maybe it's caitlyn jenner who knows it
could be anybody
right like really why not it's just a
woman right and a woman could be
anything
the reason i focus in on this guys is
because logical consistency is an actual
thing that matters
so this piece in the new york times
talks about how biden needs to pick
a woman michelle florinoy although she
is reported to still be a leading
contender
there's speculation that biden may
instead choose one of several men that
would be short-sighted says this
columnist
if biden nominates a respected and
highly qualified woman as the secretary
of defense he would send an important
and long overdue message
that the defense department's old norms
and biases were a disservice
not only to women working in national
security but to the country
uh because that will show that women are
welcome in national security even though
they are already welcome in national
security and everything
really really important stuff there
really good stuff okay in a second i
want to get deeper into the democrats
gender ideology
because again there are no standards the
standards are
nearly randomized they get to talk about
women's empowerment when it suits them
and then they get to say women don't
exist when it suits them
all right so on that note i have what
may be
the single greatest tweet of all time
here's the single greatest tweet of all
time
it is from charles blow of the new york
times the aptly named charles blow of
the new york times
the worst columnist there okay so he
tweeted this out yesterday
and it is just glorious it is a glorious
indicator of how
little sense gender ideology of the left
makes
because the same people who insist that
you have to have a female secretary of
defense
will also insist that female is an
arbitrary category that doesn't apply
unless you want it to apply to you which
is bizarre and makes no sense and is
completely disconnected from science and
biology and evolution
and everything else that is materially
objectively
verifiable okay so here is charles blows
glorious suite
this came on november 22nd you ready
stop doing gender reveals
gender reveals are these parties where a
woman knows that she's sorry
a vagina owner knows that she's having a
baby and uh
sorry a vagina owner knows that it he
she
may be xe
is having a ball of cells
and there's a biological sex that can be
discerned from the biological
ball of cells and then they celebrate
that there's a boy or a girl so we don't
want gender reveal party says charles
blow
stop doing gender reveals they're not
cute they're violent
violent guys all we know before a child
is born is their anatomy
they will reveal their gender it may
match your expectations of that anatomy
and it may not
if you love your child you will be
patient attentive and open
okay so a couple notes here
one gender reveal parties he says
they're not cute they're violent
so just to get this straight according
to charles blow
it is violent that you have a party for
your unborn baby
based on biological sex right you see
that your baby is a boy and you
celebrate by having a real
parties to all your friends and family
letting them know that you're about to
have a boy that's violent
taking a curette and carving out the
brains of the baby in the womb
and then sucking it into a sink that's
not violent that's choice
okay that again just to clarify
for people i'm left like carl's blow you
are doing violence to an unborn baby
by labeling it based on its sex saying
that its gender
and its sex are identical that's
violence to the unborn baby
but actually physically murdering the
baby in the womb
that is not violent that's choice
um okay that's just the beginning of the
crazy
then he gets to all we know before a
child is born as their anatomy
yes they will reveal their gender no
gender and biological sex are deeply
interconnected to pretend that these two
things
have no relation to one another is
complete idiocy that is anti-all
evidence
all evidence gender and biology are
deeply connected and to pretend that
they are utterly
the gender is some sort of free-floating
social construct that is made up by
human beings
it is so anti-biological that it boggles
the mind that people are allowed to get
away with this in the name of science
he says it may match your expectations
of that anatomy it may not if you love
the child you'll be patient attentive
and open so i have a feeling also that
this patient's attentive open standard
immediately dies as soon as a
four-year-old declares that they are a
member of the opposite sex
at that point you're not supposed to
engage in watchful waiting where you say
okay we're gonna wait and see if you
grow out of this
at that point you're supposed to start
calling the kid by the opposite sex name
you're supposed to start dressing
a boy in dresses and you're supposed to
subject them
to all sorts of ritualistic
psychotherapy designed
to gender confirm them at the age of
five in the opposite sex
because none of this makes any sense the
reason i bring this up that it makes no
sense
is because again the this sort of gender
theory
has reached the highest levels of
left-wing thinking this is not a fringe
thing
it really is not again elizabeth warren
who
for a time was considered the front
runner for the democratic nomination
literally said she'd have a transgender
child approved for secretary of
education
hey joe biden said that children should
be able to transition they should be
able to pick their gender
right this is
this is well accepted inside the halls
of democratic power the party of science
and it's being accepted in like on
health websites
okay health line health line which is a
a kind of
web md kind of site health line had a
piece just the other day
called do volvo owners like sex is the
wrong question
here's what you should ask instead so um
i agree that that is the wrong question
the first question should be what the
hell is a bulba owner not a volvo owner
a volva owner like as opposed to like a
renter
or a leaser and where do you go to
obtain such a thing you go down to your
local walmart
what happens if you wish to return it
but again to to
disparage being a woman down to the
level of just the genitalia right that's
all female hood is is the genitalia and
it's not even that because you don't
have to change your genitalia in order
for you to be considered a woman
so basically woman means nothing okay
that is in and of itself insane
but then the same people who say that
being a woman is a completely malleable
term and there is no definition of the
word woman we'll say that we need a
female secretary of defense
and also that is a historic moment when
a woman
competes in a male football game which
brings us
to this story at vanderbilt university
we'll get to that in just
one second but first let's talk about a
great podcast you should take a listen
to it's called the true underdog
podcast so i happen to love underdog
stories one of the reasons that i love
sports
i mean i think that our time here at
daily weather it's an underdog story i
mean we're an entrepreneurial company
started off really small got really big
underdog stories can help you become a
better entrepreneur that can help you
find the motivation to push forward in
life raised in a trailer park with no
clear path to success kicked out of high
school multiple times faced with
becoming a father in his teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog after hearing the words no or
you can't too many times he unleashed
the power within and started three
successful companies with his most
recent venture power home solar
skyrocketing on a path to becoming a
billion dollar enterprise
join the true underdog podcast as waller
a full-time entrepreneur of the year
shares motivational tips inspiring
stories and business building lessons
from the ground up he shares those life
experiences that of his high profile
guest to help others better themselves
as waller would tell you there's no
elevator to success the climb only
happens one step at a time let every
true underdog podcast be the step that
elevates
you learn about failure learn about
entrepreneurship check out the true
underdog podcast at trueunderdog.com or
anywhere
you get your podcast that's the true
underdog podcast at trueunderdog.com
alrighty coming up we're going to get to
the bizarre gender ideology
of the left which simultaneously
suggests that females and males do not
exist and also that it is deeply
important when a biological female
competes
in a male competition but first if you
are not already a daily wire member
now is the time to join we've got some
unbelievably cool stuff coming right
around the corner so
starting this friday december 4th the
michael knowles show god help us
is going five days a week with more
content for our members to enjoy
also we are adding the entire prageru
catalog to dailywear.com by the end of
the year we've already uploaded all of
prageru's five-minute videos the candice
owens show from prageru and michael
moles book club
and the rest of the library is being
added as we speak
also early next year candace is joining
the daily wire here in nashville she'll
be launching a brand new daily wear show
in front of a live
studio audience the first thing like
this on the right ever we're launching
our first
feature film too under daily wire's
upcoming entertainment channel i've seen
it i'm an executive producer on it
it's kind of awesome it's kind of
awesome we're getting into the space the
left does not want us to be in we're
getting into culture we're building a
new investigative journalism team
to replace the legacy media cartel as
well we are ambitious this year
and we need your help so go outside the
narrative come on over to dailywear.com
subscribe we are allowed we are
opinionated we are having a good time
and we are changing the nature of the
debate
with your help you want to fight back
against the legacy media no better way
to do it then join us here at dailywire
go to dailywire.com subscribe today
if you haven't ordered them yet check
out our daily wire christmas ornaments
yes that would be all of us the daily
wire host plus god king jeremy boring
as santa's adorable elves yes even i the
orthodox jew
made out of painted metal so ornaments i
don't have all that much to say about
them since i am a hanukkah celebrator
but
i have been told they are both amusing
and shiny so they are going fast get
yours right now
text christmas to 83 400 check out our
ornaments
today text christmas to 83 400 and check
out those ornaments today
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so as i keep saying there's this bizarre
idea on the left
that both gender does not exist it's a
social construct and also that it is
deeply deeply important in every
possible way they have the same feeling
about race race is a social construct
that doesn't really exist
which again i think there's more content
to that than there is to the gender idea
because the lines between races are
are actually somewhat malleable uh there
is actual crossover between
races uh the vast majority of
differences between races can be chalked
up to cultural differences rather than
innate genetic differences
skin color is mostly just skin deep
almost entirely just
skinny that is not the case with men and
women there are obvious biological
differences and that has impact in a
wide variety
and ranges of life that exists in every
culture across humankind and male and
female
are the biological predicates for all of
mammalian species right for all
procreation
males and females different in every
mammalian species okay so
at the same time that they are claiming
that gender is a
free-floating social construct they will
suggest it is very very important
for women to break barriers by for
example competing with men
right so men can compete with women if
they say they are women is the idea but
also if a woman competes with the men it
is important that she maintain the fact
that she is woman's that we know that
she can break the barriers again none of
this makes
any sense which brings us to the the
heroism of sarah fuller now sarah fuller
seems like an amazing athlete okay she's
a way better athlete than i will ever be
obviously
right she was the soccer goalkeeper for
vanderbilt university
and she played in the uh she played in
the power five
over the weekend and she was named the
special teams player of the week and she
kicked a squib kick to start off the
second half of saturday's game against
missouri
vanderbilt lost the game 41-0
so i'm not sure like that's nice
okay i'm not sure why that is like a
major achievement for women it seems
like major achievements for women would
generally be like a major achievement
for a man but a woman did it
it wouldn't be like she did a thing that
a man did but not as well as a man and
therefore it's a major achievement for a
woman to do a thing that a man could do
but not nearly as well as a man would do
it
like that that's not a major achievement
right a major she's a she's
an amazing athlete she's an amazing
women's soccer star
okay that is not the same as being like
amazing on the men's team in football
that's not the same thing and it's not a
major achievement for a woman
to do something that a man could do in a
men's game and not do it like amazingly
well
so she but affirmative action applies
when it comes to the way the media cover
these things
the sec announced her as the special
teams player of the week
fuller made history she became the first
woman ever to officially take the field
during a football game in a major
conference football game now she didn't
actually like take a tackle it wasn't
like jj watt like went right at her
right and tackled her because that would
be incredibly dangerous but the
announcement says
she took the opening kickoff of the
second half against the tigers as her
perfectly executed kick sailed 30 yards
and was down at the missouri 35-yard
line
okay um so i
um so
30 yards i mean
better than i could do i mean i'm just
going to keep saying that because that's
where twitter goes like well she's
better
yes granted she can kick the ball
further than i can i also
did not aspire to play on the vanderbilt
football team
nor do i have the physical capacity to
do so let's just show
film of this kick the greatest kick
apparently of all time like in all of
history
here she was kicking off the second half
for vanderbilt university and this was
the great historic moment for which she
won the special teams
player of the week award
[Applause]
35 um that did not tail that was not
um happy thanksgiving so what a day
right as a squid kick
what a day in college football what a
day
she kicked a ball no one is anywhere
within
a thousand yards of her she kicked it
maybe 25 yards and then it bounced like
another five
and um what a day huge huge
step for win no see i think big steps
for women are like you know i'm just
gonna say this
my wife does more for women and for
women's empowerment than sarah fuller
kicking a ball on a men's football team
with no chance of actually playing i
mean
i'm sorry but like kicking a ball 20
yards and having no chance of being
tackled is not exactly like what we mean
when we think of people
playing football so much i mean like
that's that's nice she's a soccer player
she's a great
why is it not enough for her to just be
a great soccer player i don't understand
okay my wife
who is a doctor and has three children
that seems like more of a
groundbreaking thing for women to do is
to be a doctor
right because women can be just as great
as men and being a doctor but
to treat this like this was like an
amazing performance is
kind of incredible okay the the other
person
who won the uh who won
the special teams player of the week was
cadarius tony
um and i just um i want to look up what
he actually
did last week okay so he actually scored
on a punt return
okay so that seems like more important
than not kicking a football all that
well in a game that you lose 41-0
so he earned special teams player of the
week co-special teams player of the week
for the sec
he returned to punt 50 yards which ended
up being the
touchdown that gave the gators a 1410
edge at halftime
he also scored a passing rushing
receiving and punch punt return
touchdown in a career that was the first
punt return touchdown
since an 85 yarder in 2018 for the
florida gators
um on the year he has 45 receptions for
541 yards and seven touchdowns
and slightly more impressive i think
than kicking a ball like 20 yards and
having no chance of being tackled
but again people are well but yes but
it's groundbreaking for a woman okay if
you have to add for a woman it's not
groundbreaking
seriously because you're demonstrating
that the woman is not playing on the
same level as the men
if you have to have that was a great
performance for a woman
it would have to be a great performance
for a man in a man's sport for it to be
truly groundbreaking okay but that's not
where the the absurdity stops so
apparently
sarah fuller i'm not kidding you gave a
halftime speech
to the team according to joe kinsey at
outkick
hey espn reporter courtney cronin jumped
on a zoom call to chat with fuller about
her time on the vandy football team
and that's when we learned that fuller
was given the floor to address her
fellow football players
if i'm gonna be honest i was a little
pissed off at how quiet everybody was on
the sideline fuller told cronin we made
it first down and i was the only one
cheering i was like what the heck
what's going on and i tried to get them
pumped up and i was like you guys need
to start
cheering your team on my main thing was
during the sec tournament my entire team
was cheering the entire time
it didn't matter if we were in the
locker room or if they were on the
sidelines i think that's what won it for
us everyone was cheering non-stop
i just went in there and i said exactly
what i was thinking i was like we need
to be cheering each other on this is how
you win games this is how you get better
by calling each other out for stuff and
i'm gonna call
you guys out we need to be supporting
one another if we get a first down if an
interception happens it's our fault we
need to be lifting each other up that's
what a team is about
i think this team has struggled and
that's been part of it okay she's been
part of the team for 32 seconds and she
kicked
a squib kick okay first of all it is not
a perfectly executed squib kick
okay i just you don't have to be a
football expert to understand when a
squib kick is used a squib kick is used
at the end usually of the first half
when you are just trying to run out the
clock and you don't want to see somebody
run it back you never use a squip kick
when you are down one million points at
the beginning of the second half
and give field position to the other
team 35-yard line anyway
okay but she's been on the team for like
half a second and she's lecturing
all the male players about what a winner
she is in a completely different sport
with women
that is not effective i mean can you can
you imagine the temerity of that
seriously like just the absolute goal of
that to walk into the men's football
team
these guys by the way are getting
crushed out there right not just like
they're losing they're getting
physically mauled out there because
that's what football is
these guys are going out there and
getting stomped on yeah linebackers who
are getting bruised up and you get this
woman walking in the front door she
squib kicks it 20 yards and she's like
i think that you guys are losers i think
and you know what i'm gonna lecture you
about how to be winners and the way
that we can be winners is by cheering
each other on guys we're gonna cheer
like there's no tomorrow we're gonna
cheer and that's gonna bring
the entire team together female
empowerment
she says i hope i gained their respect
it wasn't dylan tensioned at all i just
want this team to succeed
and do well so uh uh
okay so again a few notes one jason
whitlock has noted
that um that she was practicing all week
long she didn't try a field goal because
the team didn't score the entire game
but her longest field goal i believe she
says is 38 yards
which is great for any
person who is not a male football player
in an sec team right if you're in the
power five
you got to be able to get more than a
38-yard field goal in any case
the vanderbilt coach came out and said
that the kick went exactly where it was
supposed to and also i didn't want to
over coach her
i don't think there was a chance of that
i don't think it was like if you over
coached her she was going to squib kick
at 15 yards
here's the coach who by the way now has
no job he was fired because his team
stinks
we tried to go with the most naturals
the the most natural kicks
like in her arsenal um tried not to you
know
you know over coach her but let her you
know do
and understand you know uh what what
felt comfortable to her
and that's really what we went with uh
man and i thought she punched it exactly
where she needed to punch it
um falls down 35-yard line let's go
um so that was the normally you don't
actually build
like an entire play calling situation
around a kicker who only kicks the ball
about 25 yards like that's that's
normally not what you
do so can we stop pretending that this
is like some great historic breakthrough
for women women are not going to be
populating
the power 5 anytime soon wake me when a
woman is playing quarterback for a power
five team or linebacker or wide receiver
or cornerback
or anything that is not a kicker who if
they were a dude would not be
on the team obviously also i just got to
point this out again the differences
between men and women
are very real and this actually
underscores that there are differences
between men and women because if there
were no differences then she would not
be on the team
obviously nor would she win sec
co-player of the week with a guy who ran
back a 50-yard punt return
for university of florida anyway the the
halftime speech really gets me it really
does because again it again betrays the
difference between
men and women differences that are very
real okay one of those differences
is how men talk in the locker room
versus how women talk
in the locker room so women when it
comes to halftime speeches
apparently according to the book top dog
which is an excellent book by poe
bronson and ashley merriman
uh about the science of competition
talks about how men and women are
motivated by different things right
because men and women are not
exactly the same i know this is very
controversial stuff because
again we're supposed to simultaneously
believe that men and women are exactly
the same but also they are not exactly
the same so it's historic when a woman
plays in a man's game
so in any case they're not motivated by
the same thing so she's on the sideline
like why aren't you guys cheering for
each other i want more solidarity i want
more team spirit
none of that motivates dudes none of
that motivates dudes that is not how
dudes get motivated
dudes get motivated by al pacino in any
given sunday screaming in people's faces
and telling them that they're acting
like pansies so get out there and prove
that you're not a pansy
women are motivated by solidarity
they're motivated by compassion
these are things okay so you know who
says this not me
because if i say it then it's very bad
anson dorans who is the unc
women's soccer coach right one of the
great women's soccer coaches of all time
he coached the men's team at unc
university of north carolina and then
coached the women's team and here's what
he said
quote the single bet is from top dog the
single best example of how dorians
coaches women
is in his halftime speech when he
coached men dorian's best ever halftime
speech
was when he got so mad he kicked a trash
can through a window i drove that sucker
through a window and i stormed out he
recalled in the man watching let me tell
you something about
human evolution that spoke volumes to
the men in the room in the second half
everything changed
all of a sudden we had great energy
tactics shape and the game totally
turned around
some men he feels need shock to wake
them up top men are so used to
competition that even being on the
losing end at halftime is not shock
enough
but he would never treat women that way
as dorant said
quote if they've played poorly he still
comes swarming in like a cage tiger but
because these are women they can sense
immediately that you're upset
the critical thing is tone you turn to
face them and you calmly say well what
do you think
now you can hear a course of
self-flagellation as every woman in the
room is taking full responsibility for
the disaster taking place
i haven't criticized anyone i don't need
to because they're their own worst
critics
and now when the halftime talk ends
they're willing to die for you because
all you've done
is support them okay so again
i i love that she comes in she's like
i'm going to turn this male team around
by lecturing them about togetherness
and all the guys like what is this now
what is it but men and women
exactly the same in every possible way
prove that they're exactly the same
is that we put a woman on the field and
celebrated her and had
today show interviews with her and
talked about how historic it was
when she kicked a ball not all that far
in a game that her team lost by 41
points
so well done everybody gender ideology
making zero sense every single day
every single day okay meanwhile
it is time for the election update so
quick election update for you so last
night
arizona certified its votes uh the doug
ducey the governor of arizona
he announced that the vote had been
certified and
here is what that sounded like the votes
have been tabulated
all 15 counties have certified their
results
in addition to certification with
senator elect
mark kelly winning the general election
i will be signing official documentation
today
that will be hand delivered to the
secretary of the united states senate
so that arizona's newest senator can be
sworn into office
as swiftly as possible so naturally doug
ducey received inordinate crap
from a lot of people including president
trump who tweeted out why is he rushing
to put a democrat in office especially
when so many horrible things concerning
voter fraud
are being revealed at the hearing going
on right now and then he hashtagged oann
what is going on with doug ducey
republicans will long remember
and then last night he also retweeted
why bother voting republican
from another account uh this guy had
tweeted out watching the arizona
hearings and then watching governor
ducey sign those papers
why bother voting for republicans if
what you get is ducey and kemp trump
retweeted that
well i mean the pretty obvious answer is
so the socialists don't win
john ossoff who's running in georgia has
stated openly that he is embracing
bernie sanders
according to the atlanta journal
constitution ossoff's embrace of bernie
sanders highlights shift
for georgia democrats three years ago
when assaf was
running to flip a republican-controlled
suburban atlanta house district the
democrat likely would have sidestepped a
question
about bernie sanders now he says i
welcome his support his advocacy for
ensuring that healthcare is a human
right in this country
for putting the interests of working
family over corporate interest is
welcome is necessary
is appreciated and so is his support
both ossoff and raphael warnock are wild
leftists both of them running for the
senate the reason that you vote in those
races
is because those races are not fixed
okay they are not fixed
if they were fixed john ossoff would not
have trailed david perdue by about a
hundred thousand votes
in the account that happened in georgia
doug ducey put out a threat about the
situation in arizona he says i've been
pretty outspoken about arizona's
election system
and bragged about it quite a bit
including in the oval office and for
good reason we've been doing early
voting since 1992
arizona didn't explore or experiment
this year we didn't cancel election day
voting as some push for
we weren't going to disenfranchise any
voter in arizona we have some of the
strongest election laws in the country
laws that prioritize accountability and
clearly layout procedures for conducting
canvassing
even contesting the results of an
election we've got id at the polls we
review every
signature every single one on early
ballots by hand unlike other states that
use computers
prohibitions on ballot harvesting
bipartisan poll observers clear
deadlines including no ballots allowed
after election day
the problems that exist in other states
simply don't apply here i've said all
along i'm going to follow the law
the law says that the secretary of state
in the presence of the governor and the
ag
has to canvas the election on the fourth
monday following the general that was
yesterday
he says that can only be delayed if
counties declined to certify all 15
counties republican and democrat
certified their results
the canvas triggers a five-day window
for electors to bring a credible
challenge
he says now's the time to do it if you
want to contest the results now is the
time to bring the challenge that's the
law
and so i've had to follow the law ducey
is not wrong about that now is the time
to bring forward the evidence not
speculation
actual evidence or nothing is going to
change okay bottom line is
either something's going to change or
nothing is going to change and right now
unless evidence is brought forth in
places like arizona
nothing is going to change remember
trump would need to win georgia arizona
and pennsylvania
all states in which he has been
certified as the not winner right now as
it stands
in order to take the election okay
meanwhile
time for your quick covet updates okay
it's covid time so
apparently there are now two vaccines
that are heading to the fda for review
setting scientific speed records
according to the washington post the
federal government could begin
distributing two coronal virus vaccines
in the next few weeks
moderna filed monday for emergency
authorization of its covet vaccine
capping a scientific sprint that began
in january modernist two-dose regimen is
about a week behind a similar vaccine
developed by pfizer
and uh bioentech so apparently that
means that millions of doses are going
to go out in the next
couple of weeks approximately 40 million
doses of two remarkably effective
vaccines could be available by the end
of the year enough for 20 million people
to receive a full protection the madonna
vaccine actually didn't just show 94.1
effectiveness apparently in lowering the
severity of the disease it showed 100
effectiveness which is just amazing
amazing news
anthony fauci director of the nia id he
said you don't want to get ahead of
yourself and claim victory that says the
makings of a very very important
positive impact on ending this outbreak
by the way
it is true that this thing could have
been out weeks earlier if it were not
for the fda
if it were not for the fda holding up
the process this thing could have been
up
it could have been out a couple of weeks
earlier which would presumably have
saved some tens of thousands of lives
given the trajectory of the virus right
now
so this is obviously very very good news
as it currently
stands the secretary of health and human
services alex azar he announced that the
vaccines are going to be shipping within
24 hours
it'll ship within 24 hours after fda
approval
and then really it's going to be up to
our nursing homes our hospitals our
pharmacies to get that dispense so
it really could be within within days of
fda approval we'll start seeing vaccines
in people's arms which
is frankly incredible think about this
10 months into this pandemic hitting our
shores
thanks to what president trump has done
here we believe we're going to have
people getting vaccinated
millions of people before christmas this
year it's just
unheard of in the history of public
health this accomplishment
i mean it is an amazing amazing
accomplishment meanwhile anthony fauci
announced yesterday that he thinks it's
a good
a good idea for kids to go back to
school i just want to point out here
that the follow the science crowd
if they'd been following anthony fauci
when it comes to schools reopening
he's been all over the damn place i mean
all over the place
seriously like some of us have been
saying there's no evidence that schools
should be closed as early as like april
or may
i was an early adopter of the schools
should be open kids are not transmitting
this thing in mass numbers and schools
are not major vectors
of transmission kids are safe from the
virus particularly elementary school
kids
but here is just a brief montage of
anthony fauci flip-flopping all over the
place about whether schools should be
open or closed this is why
you place your faith in any one public
figure and it is likely to be
disappointed
i know that we've decided to make
anthony fauci the saint of covid because
he opposed donald trump from time to
time but um the idea that if you
followed
fauci you would have been taking a
consistent line is just not true here is
anthony fauci since march
talking about various positions on
school reopenings
we have to start implementing both
containment and mitigation
and what was done when you do closing
the school there's mitigation
if you have a situation in which you
don't have a real good control
over an outbreak and you allow children
to gather together they likely will get
infected
we don't know everything about this
virus and we really better be very
careful particularly when it comes to
children
i think we better be careful if we are
not cavalier
in thinking that children are completely
immune to the deleterious effects
there may be some areas that the level
of virus is so high
that it would not be prudent to bring
the children back to school
the default position should be
to try as best as you possibly can
to open up the schools for in-person
learning
if you're in a situation in the in a
green zone where you have a very low
level of infection and test positivity
that in general
you can open the schools with impunity
close the bars and keep the schools open
is what we really say
okay that was him like march april may
again the point here is that if you
followed the quote-unquote science
then you would have had a consistent
position since april there have been no
major outbreaks from schools
anywhere on earth for elementary school
kids anywhere on earth and they were
open throughout europe
and yet fouchy was all over the place on
this thing never put your trust in one
single public official
it is always always always a mistake
that is particularly true when you're
talking about
elected officials who create rules the
intensive structure on covet is
completely screwed up at this point i
mean utterly and completely screwed
from beginning to end because if you're
a public official
and you've created this panic about kova
that millions are going to die from
covet that your chances of death are
incredibly high
basically no matter which sort of
pre-existing conditions you have no
matter your age
if you've created that level of panic
then the incentive structure is that
you're supposed to lock things down
what happens if you've already locked
everything down what if you're la
la county and you already locked down
all the indoor dining you did it like
two weeks ago
and the spike is continuing because
nobody can control this thing
and you've created in this outsized
panic about how millions of people are
going to die the health system is going
to be swamped right now by the way
there's still healthcare capacity
millions of people are not going to die
in the united states from covenant 19 a
lot of people have died from covenant 19
in the united states
there are almost entirely people who
have had fairly significant pre-existing
conditions
johns hopkins university did a study
they found that of the people who have
died of covet 19 who are on medicare
which means everybody above the age of
65 essentially in the country
of all the people above 65 that's the
bulk of the people who've died from
cover 19.
of all those people above the age of 65
the number of people
who are otherwise healthy who didn't
have other pre-existing conditions who
died of copen
is 2 500 according to dr martinez out of
267 thousand
doesn't mean the virus isn't more
dangerous than the flu it is more
dangerous than the flu and it's
particularly more dangerous than the flu
if you have pre-existing conditions
right it's not really even if you're
elderly it's more if you have any sort
of serious preexisting condition like
obesity not just your overweight
obesity or if you have renal failure or
if you have heart
disease and not just hypertension but
like serious heart disease
right these are things that are going to
complicate obviously
but the media have done an
extraordinarily poor job of bringing you
the information so this sets up
a system where politicians are basically
benefited by shutting things down so
gavin newsom was again
warning that it was time to shut down
more of the california
i can't i'm so happy i'm not in that
that horror-stricken state
this ken doll of a human talking about
shutting down more of the state
l.a county shut down outdoor dining
there is no evidence outdoor dining is a
vector of transmission
here is gavin newsom threatening this
stuff i mean at least when he's not at
the french laundry eating indoors with
california medical association officials
if these trends continue we're going to
have to take much more
dramatic arguably drastic action
including
taking a look at those purple tiered
counties the potential for
a stay-at-home order for those regions
in purple because of hospitalizations
and icus
to make determinations of deep purple
moves in those purple-tiered status
that is more equivalent more in line
with the stay-at-home order
uh that folks were familiar with in the
beginning of
this year so they're gonna lock you in
your house really exciting stuff
out there in california unless you're
one of the unless you're one of the
elite right then if you're gavin newsom
again go to the french laundry
best thing i saw yesterday was some
local restaurant had put up a sign in
l.a county that said the french laundry
outdoor patio just over its normal sign
because of course gavin newsom had eaten
at this very expensive 400
a plate dinner at the french laundry by
the way it's not just gavin newsom
according to nbc bay area san jose mayor
ignored health protocols during holiday
celebration
why there's a shocker turns out the
denver mayor did the same thing by the
way
denver mayor was like we gotta shut this
thing down no traveling for thanksgiving
i however will be visiting my parents
right andrew cuomo tried to do the same
thing he was like nobody visit your
parents over thanksgiving also
also my mother is coming she's coming
out here i got mom out there
and i got my kids they're all coming in
we're gonna hang out together we're
gonna swap spit it's gonna be great
and then he's like maybe i shouldn't
have said that so now san jose mayor sam
licardo
appears to have broken health protocols
in celebrating thanksgiving with family
members outside of his own household
the nbc bay area investigative unit has
learned licardo celebrated with his
elderly parents
at their saratoga home with an unknown
number of other guests
while the mayor's staff did confirm that
dinner took place they haven't disclosed
how many other people attended how many
different households were present and
whether any of those in attendance wore
masks while not eating
this is a private event not public said
jim reed licardo's chief of staff
oh is it now so the same public health
officials who are like
red on your neighbor if you see they're
having dinner with their parents they're
like this is a public this isn't a
public event it's private
jim reid location chief of staff said we
are going to redraw the line between
what is personal and what is public
because that line has become blurred
so good times there with sam ricardo
meanwhile how is
la county using its federal coveted
relief funds
get ready for this one this is great
emily's an audience daily wire reporting
l.a county
used millions in federal coronavirus
relief dollars meant to help struggling
californians stay afloat during extended
pandemic related economic lockdowns
to fund no-bid contracts with two pr
agencies who recruited celebrity
influencers to help spread coronavirus
messaging on social media
a local media investigation revealed l.a
county has extended agreements with two
pr firms
hired to guide the county's coven 19
messaging and is using federal karezak
money to offset part of the cost of
their contract
which now total 2.9 million
dollars the contracts were no bid they
were first inked backed in early 2020.
the county has now extended those
contract apparently the pr firms can
hire celebrities to convince the public
of the importance of covet abatement
measures
apparently the county defended the
expense they said expanded activities
including
response to hundreds of requests each
week from media partners creating and
disseminating new culturally and
linguistically appropriate educational
materials
daily through various communications
channels and participating in dozens of
briefings each week
each week to provide information and
respond to concerns
so yes they hired like instagram
influencers to tell you to put on a mask
and they did that with taxpayer funding
solid solid stuff by the way
uh the la county supervisors you know
they're the ones who voted to shut down
the uh the outdoor restaurants this is
fox la reporting
just hours after la county supervisor
sheila cool
backed to voted to ban outdoor dining at
la county's 31 thousand restaurants over
covent safety concerns
she visited a restaurant in santa monica
where she dined outdoors
no no that be impossible
cool was seen dining outside at ilforno
trattoria in santa monica an italian
restaurant near her house
when fox 11 investigative reporter bill
mclugan stopped by the restaurant to ask
about it managers said they didn't want
to get involved but had no comment
a spokesperson said she did dine
alfresco at ilforno on the very last day
it was permissible
she loves alforno has been saddened to
see it like so many restaurants suffer
from a decline in revenue
she ate there taking appropriate
precautions and sadly will not dine
there again
until our public health orders permit
she's just sneaking it in right under
the wire because as we all know
covet obeys public health rules so
really really solid stuff speaking of
hypocrisy
so the the greatest governor in america
andrew cuomo
that guy um he uh he said yesterday
that it was a nightmare that coveted was
spiking again and that they were facing
a nightmare scenario in
new york state here was andrew cuomo
talking about it yesterday
we lived this nightmare we learned from
this nightmare
and we're going to correct for the
lessons we learned
during this nightmare if we had a real
hospitalization crisis
we could potentially do a new york pause
california just did a california pause
which is basically a stop
or move one zone to another if we have a
critical hospital situation
okay meanwhile uh you know that briefing
that he's doing right there
um cuomo and his aides i have a picture
of it
he's in a closed room with uh nobody
wanting a mask
yep solid stuff according to the new
york post governor andrew cuomo
crowds reporters that his push for mask
wearing helped curb new york
new york's kova 19 cases while his
tone-deaf panel of aids sat in the
clothes room without ever putting their
masks
on what worked in the spring and the
reason you're wearing a mask today is
because we told the truth and new
yorkers responded said the governor
cuomo was not wearing a mask at the time
nor were his five top aides on the dais
including state health commissioner
howard zucker and suny chancellor jim
alatras
the governor's spokespeople photographer
and state trooper detail had masks on so
did all the reporters
his panel of his panels flaunting what
would seem to be no-brainer precautions
comes after cdc has warned on its
website there's evidence under certain
conditions people with coven 19 seem to
have infected others who are more than
six feet
away he was speaking most of the time in
monday's presser he and his people were
six feet apart but the room is so tight
journalists have been limited because
there's not enough space
i mean just amazing amazing stuff again
the rules don't apply to the specials
they don't apply to the special people
also in breaking covet news remember
that time that it was very bad to label
the uh
the wuhan virus the wuhan virus you
weren't allowed to talk about it well
now
cnn which suggested that it was
xenophobic for you to talk about the
fact that this virus started in china
they have a large-scale report from nick
patton walsh titled the wuhan files
leaked documents reveal china's
mishandling of the early stages of covet
19.
a group of frontline medical workers
likely exhausted
stand huddled together on a video
conference call as china's most powerful
man
raises his hand in greeting it is
february 10th in beijing and president
xi jinping who for weeks has been absent
from public view is addressing hospital
staff in the city of wuhan
as they battle to contain the spread of
a still officially unnamed novel
coronavirus from a secure room
about 1200 kilometers from the epicenter
xi expressed his condolences to people
who had died
here's greater public communication that
same day chinese authorities reported
2 400 new confirmed cases raising the
total global number to more than 40
000 with fewer than 400 cases occurring
outside mainstream
out of mainland china yet cnn can now
reveal
how official documents circulated
internally show this was only part of
the picture
in a report marked internal document
please keep confidential local health
authorities in the province of cuba
where the virus was first detected
listed a total of nearly 6 000 newly
detected cases on february 10th more
than double the official public number
of confirmed cases
the larger figure was never fully
revealed at the time
it seems to downplay the severity of the
outbreak the previously undisclosed
figure is among a string of revelations
contained within 117 pages of leaked
documents from the hubei provincial
center for center for disease control
and prevention
shared with and verified by cnn taken
together the documents amount to the
most significant leak from inside china
since the beginning of the pandemic and
provide the clear first window into what
local authorities knew internally
and when this is my favorite sentence
you ready
the documents provide no evidence of a
deliberate attempt to obfuscate findings
but they do reveal numerous
inconsistencies
in what authorities believe to be
happening and what was revealed to the
public
i think that's called the deliberate
attempt to obfuscate findings
but if you actually know something is
going on and then you don't want to
reveal it to the public that would be
obfuscating your findings by definition
would it not
the documents reveal what appears to be
an inflexible healthcare system
constrained by top-down bureaucracy and
rigid procedures that were ill-equipped
to deal
with the emerging crisis the documents
show evidence of clear missteps point to
a pattern of institutional failings
one of the most striking data points
concerns the slowness with which kova 19
patients were diagnosed
even as authorities in hubei presented
their handling of the initial outbreak
to the public as efficient and
transparent as cnn
the documents show that local health
officials were reliant on flawed testing
and reporting mechanisms
a report in the document from early
march says the average time between
onset of symptoms to confirm diagnosis
was 23.3 days nearly a month
china has defended its handling of the
outbreak
but of course the they would right i
mean they're they're a communist
tyranny they didn't just make mistakes
okay they they covered everything up
because again this is a communist
tyranny
we now have evidence by the way that uh
the wuhan virus was present in the
united states as early as december that
is some new evidence that is emerging
today and the world got more optimistic
data than reality
china kept telling people that there
weren't that many cases but
there are a lot more cases than that and
they kept saying that
fewer people were dead than the number
of people who were dead
they wildly reported the number of daily
dead
so just really solid stuff there from
from china
but don't worry the who is on top of it
and it's very bad to mention this is a
china-based virus
just terrible they were china and cnn
were busy blaming trump for all of us
and so it's only now you know after the
election that we hear about the china
flu again
when as it turns out it was in fact the
wuhan flew all along
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. hey
everybody it's andrew clavin host of the
andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing
the end of days is approaching and the
moon has turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton
you